welcome back to new rockstars I'm Eric
Boston this is a breakdown of Rick and
Morty season 4 episode 6 it's back never
Ricky Morty aka the train that
definitely left the station and derailed
and crashed through all of our dreams I
did my best to explain what was and
wasn't canon in this episode with Rick
and Morty insiders on our after-show
over-explain go check it out but here
I'm gonna go even deeper to point out
the subtle animation jokes and easter
eggs and clever details hidden
throughout the episode you know the
reasons we still believe in our animated
Lord and saviors even if they don't
believe in us this episode takes place
on this story train conducted by the
story Lord who wants to drain Morty and
Rick of their narrative imagination to
keep the train chugging along each part
of the train is a metaphor for anthology
storytelling as a concept the short
standalone stories within a meta framing
device the device in this case is the
Train on this train Rick recognizes its
structure as within Dan Harmon's story
circle formula all of the events on and
off the train happened but two versions
of these characters since they're all on
a toy train the Morty and Rick of the
final scene are cannon we think as Kanan
as Rick and Morty can be leaving us with
the cynical moral of buying merch which
is really the fuel that keeps Rick and
Morty as a vehicle chugging along you
did it
you went into a store an actual
honest-to-god store and you bought
something it was titled never Ricky
Morty is of course a nod to the never
Indians story the 80s movie about a
story within a story that I will repeat
drowned
artax in a swamp really I would say the
episodes conceits it's closer to bong
Joon hos films snowpiercer
in which these survivors of a
post-apocalyptic society all of aboard a
fantastical train which is really a
Marxist allegory for a capitalist class
structure I guess think it also say it's
similar to infinity train but if you've
seen snowpiercer you'll know this is
closer to snowpiercer in the first bar
card beer taps include a killer IPA for
corn populist Michael from the Morty
night run episode the other tap is Viper
a snake head maybe like the snake planet
from the previous episode round star
Rick lactic ax which only came out like
five months ago but feels like five
goddamn years ago on each table or
dispensers for brass knuckles one of the
drink tanks has a creature floating in
it
and there's a wanted poster for 3
million schmuck holes in the background
the ticket taker is a nod to characters
like the creepy conductor in the Polar
Express a movie whose last stop is an
uncanny valley Hell where Robert
Zemeckis believes animated characters
should have no souls this character is
voiced by Dan Harmon the assassin
recalls a time Ric attacked his planet
notice how in his tail Rick only speaks
via fart who are you how did you reach
my sanctum alright this is going in
circles
[Music]
later on the assassin and maybe way he
does a different version of the story
where I start crying or something yeah
they're playing with the unreliable
narrator trope where the reality of the
tale reflects the bias of the narrator
one of the many anthology storytelling
elements that come up this episode
similarly the episode doesn't follow the
first narrator but leaves him behind
following the audience as another Rando
joins in I'll take his turn here's why
I'm going to kill Rick Sanchez have fun
with this resolve to a clam shaped Sun
rising over a giant thief's clam woman
uses these same cringy screenplay
language as the lighthouse keeper and
look who's purging now fade in exterior
a named City day hustle and bustle is a
symphony of progress we pan past Windows
each of which contain a different story
you see kind of foreshadows the ending
of this episode sunrise on a beach with
story Lord and Jesus walking along that
Beach which itself is a nod to the two
sets of footprints Jesus story whose
then I was carrying yeah goomy's
Christmas Rick tail ends with him left
alone outside in the cold
similar to Jerry in the season 3 episode
but also holiday movies like home alone
and planes trains and automobiles both
of which have tragic scenes with
characters without families freezing to
death in the Chicago winter sadly the
two sets of footprints for Gumi meant no
one was carrying him Morty's disguised
as an assassin voiced by prolific voice
actor Tara Strong
she meets Rick's exes which include a
female Yoda
maybe ya know a three boobed alien an
octopus with a captain hat and a garter
belt an Amazon woman Lea appears to be a
white witch figure her planet has a
direwolf and family includes sisters who
appear to be based on Anna and Elsa from
frozen also may be Aldrich from Dark
Souls and some idiot who's just the
concept of time love the sky we learned
that these two assassins are actually
Rick and Morty in disguise Rick knows
from the moment Morty feels his own
boobs which make a great balloon to flee
sound effect Rick discovers a train's
truth as a literal story device
comparing this overwritten anthology
trope to past clip show episodes like
interdimensional cable we wanted one off
so we do interdimensional cable not some
uptight over it the tickets please guy
goes shirtless Jesus the tickets please
guy is cut these keys got those things
what do you call them I'm gonna woody
grows people call them nice people to
swim to deep into this gutter but just
so you know gutters is where the the
v-shape is the writers admitted finding
this term super gross and a bit
confusing whose is being guttered your
own I don't where is it
guttering to disgusting also notice that
morty says jesus he's cut maybe
unintentionally invoking cut jesus in
this episode's finale th police guy is
another story trope of course a video
game avatar in deep lips and shit's
arcade much like royal life well-lived
and morty knight run as it's typical in
those kind of stories dying in the
virtual reality or in the dream leads to
death in the surface reality horrible
horrible death back on the drain the
oxygen they breathe is continuity since
story continuity episode ebb so it is
really the basic element that maintains
order on the series the story police
give another meta-narrative trope
everything we just saw is actually a
what not to do training video in which
continuity has exploded so when Morty
and rick pop up from nowhere with rick's
crushed leg healed they're using the
rules of anthology storytelling and
discontinuity to respawn in a new car
rick breaks down the episode structure
using a parody of Dan Harmon's 8-step
story circle I go much more into that
endeavour explained episode again check
it out when he says pay a heavy price he
points to the threshold right at step 7
brewing to the threshold between the
take and the return step typically when
a character dies in this episode that's
exactly when Rick passes out notice the
recycling bin by the desk this couldn't
you joke about how the writers are kind
of recycling the anthology concept from
interdimensional cable and Morty's mind
blowers but while I'm doing something
new with it this is just a structural
guide we're obviously gonna impart our
own style and then Rick it's uh close to
home you watch videos of people on
YouTube reacting to YouTube's fair
enough in the future I'll know better
than to assume Canon from Rick and Morty
YouTube trailer
notice the tickets please guy floating
around outside how is he still breathing
suspended and disbelief slowly dying
while living out an alternative
non-diegetic reality she's what a
horrible way to die you don't know the
half of it of this word flakes suspended
in disbelief non-diegetic yeah they're
more story structure terms about
audience assumptions of the truth of a
reality and this is just a joke about
the half body they're laughing at the
idea of a slow horrible death
in a meadow reality being aware of your
fictitious existence which is exactly
what rick is experiencing on this show
birdperson returns at a musical duet
with rick which ends up being a story
pitch by the Broadway musical car there
are posters for past Rick and Morty
musical moments tiny Rick from big
trouble and little Sanchez get schwifty
Morty and fart from goodbye moon man the
characters are on costume ones rum tum
tugger from cats the Phantom of the
Opera the girl from hairspray the donkey
from Shrek and I want to say Tom Collins
from rent though some of you bigger
musical heads may call me out on that I
will see and then there are more posters
in the background more joke musicals the
sound of Rick and then just Rick design
like the cats poster and me six of the
Opera with a nice box up as always the
animators recycle background alien
designs as floaty blood man hoots lips
and shits you can see one of the blue
ape aliens from or leaderly floaty blood
man inspires another meta framing device
with a stoner in so-called follower
believing all of existence is within
floaties blood man's nightmares this
pig-nosed race will appear next week's
primordius episode notice the weird
fluid they're vaping and when they
exhale some kind of poor ghen is some
floats out perhaps that will be the
origin of the infection of that coming
episode and we are looking here at
patient zero yeah it's not easy finding
these details folks but just like how
Rick Sanchez stays sharp on his drink of
choice so do I
thanks to bang energy for sponsoring
this video every can of bang is 16
ounces that's right there's no wimpy 12
ounce cans here this contains 300
milligrams of caffeine it's sugar-free
as zero calories and it tastes great
this is their peach mango flavor it
tastes like you've wrapped a blindfold
around your head and you did a taste
test between a peach and a mango if
somehow it's both pieces of mango it's
sex had a kid and you're drinking in the
bang and you're
life is better there are over 20
different flavors to choose from
check out bang on Instagram you can get
25% off your order at Bank - energy calm
when you use the code new rock stars 25
I got to dive back from the page and
then go pit
there you can buy cans of bang energy
including their sweet tea Keo coffee
flavors you don't forget clothing
fitness supplements all kinds of stuff
to be your best bang self thanks again a
bang energy for sponsoring this video
get 25% off at bang - energy calm using
the code new rock stars 25 and follow
the inventor of bang on instagram at
bang energy that's CEO okay Rick gives
Morty's suit a ticking clock purposely
to motivate him which is another
Metacomet about how stories artificial
ticking clocks are inserted simply to
propel the hero into action
Morty's stammers a crappy story with
scorpions on the wall behind them is a
photo of Morty jr. but because Morty's
bad story meshes too well with the theme
of anthology stories being crappy and
low stakes land fails so Rick tries to
break the Train was something they would
never do on this dough Morty do you know
what the Bechdel test is the why for
God's sake Morty the formula for
measuring female agency in a story
proposed by lesbian cartoonist Alison
why is lesbian part of her job title now
your progressive Bechdel test is Alison
Bechdel's feminist media critique point
out how rare it is to see a scene in
which two named female characters talk
to each other about something other than
a man it's the kind of thing that's been
a bit over applied and a bit
misconstrued some critics calling it a
reductive way to form properly
progressive but flat stories but I don't
think it was ever meant to be a rule
that every movie has to follow really
here it's just a commentary about how
Dan Harmon himself regrets trying too
hard to be an ally in the past with
season ones gazorpazorp storyline which
he called his least favourite episode
because the episodes meeting just
stopped lost that is why Morty's overly
simple story with Beth and summer breaks
this train he's using them as puppets to
try to pass the Bechdel test but nothing
more than that and his faux Bechdel test
is for Morty super uninformed point of
view that's why the Scorpions have bows
and the women use their mystic
menstruation power to beat them and why
Supreme Court Justice Ruth Bader
Ginsburg shows up to congratulate them
though Morty doesn't know her name and
of course Rick who's equally ignorant
calls this the
feminist masterpiece like the climax of
snowpiercer they arrive in the engine
room to face the conductor in this case
it's a story Lord voiced by Paul
Giamatti he mocks Rick's burped
semi-improvised dialogue and also strips
down to some odors and he admits he
commits a double beat which is a writer
term for a redundant scene or a bit his
gray beard and wavy hair I don't know
guys might be based a bit on Dan
Harmon's look the fight spills in and
out of Canon with Morty and Ric
respawning and more trophy
meta-narrative scenarios a matrix style
fluid pod a Jacob's Ladder scenario
which is later revealed to be a pill
from Rick suggesting MKULTRA style
hallucinogenic testing Rick meanwhile
wakes up in a college lab setting he's a
quantum physics professor noticed the
wormhole diagrams on the board this
episode rubber also reminds us a few
times that Rick invented portal tech and
that he doesn't go on linear journeys
because he hops in and out of portals
perhaps this here is a past memory from
his early research as a young man
inventing portal tech that he's slipping
into but when Morty stabs him with a
bayonet he proves this to be another
non-canonical situation story Lord
drains them for their narrative energy
to power the trains of marketability
broad appeal and relatability the
artificial measure is a story quality
signaling to us right now that this
whole train is just a commercial product
he mentions wanting to break past the
fifth wall a nod to the fact that this
fourth wall has already been broken
through and then Rick loses some big fan
episode ideas the return of April Dolph
Winkler from season one an epic end game
style battle with snowball versus a cat
army Rick tackling phoenix person summer
and Tammy and a lightsaber duel and then
a huge stand down at the Sanitation
plant in the Citadel with Rick and Morty
faced in an army of Rick's and meeseeks
male gaze or pians all led by evil Morty
eyepatch and everything with what looks
like a purple sith lord version of mr.
poopy butthole
Rick solution is to pray to bring in cut
Jesus which is another joke about how
Harmons stories circle and the Joseph
Campbell monomyth it's based on or all
derivations of the greatest story ever
told the story of Christ and how
escalating to divine intervention grinds
every story to a halt
including this train Rick gets visited
by VeggieTales characters and Bible
Soros and crossi
I love how cross sees crown of thorns
includes a little trickle of blood they
trap story Lord in that religious
reality but they discover that
the Train handle is just a toy piece
it's got a barcode on the inside and
it's control panel is a sticker because
the ultimate meta-narrative twist it's
all a st. elsewheres style reveal that
the events are all in a child's toy here
it's a train that Morty bought in the
citadel of rick's gift shop
so this freewheelin off the rails story
that we just saw is actually on a fixed
loop designed to just sell products to
consumers so proud of you I only wish
you could have bought more I love buying
thanks so much this tank was made even
more meta by the fact that the
commercials that play during this
broadcast included Rick amore selling
Pringles and Wendy's turns out the fifth
wall is the one between the show and the
commercial break and Rick and Morty
somehow smashed through it sorry Lauren
and Jesus walked the beach yeah like
that famous story the Sumerian god named
da and a Mesopotamian god named way this
statement is based on some truths and
Santa Paula gist do believe that the
ancient Hebrew notion of Yahweh was
derived from the earlier Sumerian figure
of El Jesus escape
[Music]
I love that Jesus's power works just
like lion-o from Thundercats Rick yells
that Morty to serve their corporate
overlords buy a new train
I guess I'll return it turn are you
insane did you hear nothing I said buy
another one Morty consume Morty nobody's
out there shopping with this virus how a
virus joke
notice that Rick's mouth didn't match
the word exactly probably because Justin
roiland dubbed in this topical audio
after animation was completed the
post-credits scene is a commercial for
the story train which might be a nod to
the meta existential post-credits scene
after community season 6 for community
the board game narrated by Dan Harmon I
got it the whole show was happening
inside this game life may pass by while
we ignore him is treat those close to us
those close to us maybe those watching
those people may want to know I love
them but I may be incapable of saying it
contains pieces the size of a child's
esophagus well is your favorite joke
from this Rick and Morty episode comment
below and again check out our after-show
over-explained where Tommy and I try to
analyze this episode with the voice of
mr. goldenfold himself Brandon Johnson
follow me a TA of Australian rock stars
and subscribe for more Rick and Morty
YouTube reactions to YouTube videos I'm
on that train
[Music]